[Applauso]
[Musica]
basta basta che ho mal di testa questo
come va tutti quanti di voi mi conoscono
sulle mani gli altri possono uscire
rappresentano
semplicità e leggerezza stanno faccio
una piccola pausa
Ho preparato il discorso
semplicità leggerezza stanno insieme
perché fanno parte della stessa cosa ma
non è da confondersi con la faciloneria
non è che è facile ciò che è semplice
ciò che è semplice si indirizza una
strada ti fa capire dove devi andare
percorribile ed è imparentata Secondo me
con quel senso di come dire di cinismo
che un pochettino ci appartiene noi
milanesi che è tangibile è un po' come
quella barzelletta Avete presente quel
tale al figlio che va cade nel Naviglio
e un tale si butta e lo salva arriva il
padre e
diceti che salva Sei tu che hai
installato mio figlio fai lui sì Dov'è
il cappellino
[Risate]
questa barzelletta è illuminata Perché
ti fa capire che cos'è il cinismo quello
che serve il cinismo è una piccola come
dire una parte di quelli ironie che ci
serve per capire che la vita non è così
facile la rende un po' più leggera la
ridimensiona e il cinismo serve a
rendere leggera le cose quando diventano
pesanti non lo dico io l'ha detto
Pirandello che ragazzi
bene per andare nel frattempo per dire
quello che penso un pochettino di
leggerezza vi faccio vedere un gioco che
di solito faccio col pubblico che è
questo un sacchetto the bag of Mystery
e non sarebbe bag
in inglese perché l'inglese faceva
l'inglese parlano veramente in questo
modo di fare Avete presente nei film per
esempio lui o lei li interpreta la
mattina si alza con la colazione coi
waffle col Maple surroop poi dopo bevi
mangia i cornflash dentro una tazza
grosso come lo scudo di Capitan America
quindi deve un'aranciata che sta dentro
una bottiglia da tre Galloni mette la
tuta va fuori fa il jogging torna a casa
fa la doccia beve il caffè poi va in
ufficio Io mi alzo la mattina piscio
sono già in ritardo allora è quella roba
americana
[Musica]
più anche ci sono un fazzoletto rosso e
un fazzoletto bianco eccolo qua Si
vedono il fazzoletto rosso il fazzoletto
bianco si mettono all'interno del
sacchetto un po' di polvere magica
e il fazzoletto bianco diventa rosso
quello rosso diventa
[Applauso]
la gente dice Ma ti pagano per questo sì
avrete capito che mio padre e mia madre
erano cugini
seconda parte si mette nei fazzoletti
all'interno del sacchetto si fa così me
l'ha insegnato Silvan
quando i giochi non riescono più
attenzione
di farti cacchio Muovi le mani e il
fazzoletto rosso è ritornato rosso
per fazzoletto bianco devi stare attento
spiegazione
spiegazione per fare questo gioco perché
molti Magari non l'ha capito Magari uno
vuole impararlo per farlo con gli amici
per brillare in società per farlo coi
nipotini per fare questo gioco ci
vogliono questi componenti un sacchetto
e due fazzoletti
uno bianco e nero rosso Ma come fanno i
fazzoletti a trasformarsi Eh come fanno
ce ne sono altri due c'è un altro
fazzoletto bianco Eccolo qua e un altro
fazzoletto rosso scalda la macchina che
andiamo
ho fatto uno spettacolo con un mago che
ha tirato fuori 20 colombe da un foulard
non ha avuto gli applausi che ho io
Questo gioco è semplice
però mi apre una strada durante lo
spettacolo è semplice ma non è non è
facile è semplice è diverso nel senso
che è una gag può farla chiunque ma la
faccio io perché ho scelto perché ho
scelto di essere un antimago Cioè ho
scelto quella strada che ti porta verso
una direzione completamente diversa c'è
il mago di solito ha un'impostazione
precisa la gente si aspetta qualcosa di
importante ma ma
tu non puoi tra tu non puoi arrovellarti
e rovinarti con qualcosa di complicato
Devi ricordarti a scapito del della
riuscita No preferisco muovermi con
qualcosa che sia semplice perché ciò che
è semplice mi rende le cose più facili e
quello che voglio dire che la gente alla
gente non interessa che tu sia Bravo sia
talentato Beh certo quando vediamo un
bravo pianista ci piace quando vediamo
un bravo attore Ma la gente persona
interessata a quello che sei a quello
che fai come tipo oggi se sei simpatico
se sei simpatico e queste sono le cose
che interessano il resto non ha
importanza i comici non hanno qualcosa
che hanno i maghi per esempio dottore
nella sua biografia diceva che spesso e
volentieri poteva far ridere il pubblico
in tre maniere diverse facendogli fare
hahaha
oppure uh uh uh
oppure e lo facevano lo dimostrava
usciva e tutte le volte che rientreremo
faceva ridere pubblico in questo modo ma
anche a Totò mancava qualcosa che hanno
i maghi Cioè Oh
potete farlo anche voi tengo
quando ho cominciato pensavo che tutti i
maghi fossero come Silvano Io pensavo di
potermi esibire insieme a questi
personaggi eleganti che parlavano Come
Silvano indizione signori Guardate
attentamente Eh che cosa sto facendo
niente ma lo sta facendo tutto un mondo
di eleganza di perfezione che invece
viene tradita dalle aspettative che
erano completamente diverse perché in
realtà nelle serate che facevo io erano
tutti maghi oronzi
ci sono degli aneddoti che hanno dato
vita al mio personaggio e
sono tanti ce n'era uno che aveva
imparato a fare l'ipnosi però l'ipnosi
da piazza perché sono tanti tipi di
ipnosi cioè l'ipnosi quella scientifica
quella dei dottori esce quella
guardami un attimo negli occhi Stai
dormendo ora
questa espressione del volto è tipica di
alcuni ipnotisti da piazza che Come si
dice ipnotizzano Allora l'ipnosi da
piazza può essere fatta veramente o con
dei compari Ma quando è fatta veramente
viene fatta con l'imposizione delle mani
nelle posizioni dello sguardo
cioè questi questi ipnotizzatori da
piazza usano questa tecnica che funziona
e questo l'aveva imparata ma nel giro di
un corso aveva fatto un corso sul
dominio della parola non so che cosa ha
fatto guardavo la gente Guardami Adesso
dormi dormi
[Musica]
e aveva su questa
su questa panchina cinque persone li
addormentate è veramente tu ti guardavi
dice l'ha fatto veramente E dopo avergli
fatto fare tutte quelle cose che invece
non bisogna fargli la gallina fai il
maiale
Adesso vi sveglio quando schiocco le
dita quando uscirò con le dita vi
svegliate svegliati si svegliano tutti
meno uno
Vabbè Ragazzi andiamo
è questo qua è questo prima o poi si
sveglia
una roba così sì altri aneddoti come
questo sempre di quel signore abbiamo un
fogliettino di carta nel quale c'era il
nome di una persona è tipico del
Mentalista non vi spiego come ruba
un'informazione al pubblico in qualche
modo
nascondeva praticamente Folletto di
carta nella mano nel quale trascritto il
nome della persona che avrebbe dovuto
indovinarla che aveva di fronte aveva
scritto il nome di una persona questo
foglio a lui era riuscito a rubarlo ce
l'aveva qui nella mano e doveva
guardarlo per leggere il nome tu questo
personaggio che hai
che cercava di rubare la scrittrice
tanto faceva delle domande che nel
mentalismo si dice fishings andiamo a
pescare Cioè andiamo ad entrare è una
persona che ti è tanto cara oppure
questi gesti per arrivare a attenzione
perché qui nasce l'idea di fare il mago
Oronzo Per quale motivo nasce perché
questo qua dopo un po' grasso tu quando
quando questa persona che
se ne esce con sta battuta ma questa Ma
come cazzo scrivi
sono rimasto
sono rimasto basito perché mi sono detto
io devo fare il Mangone devo fare un
mago che parla così in quel senso devo
dire che mi sono tolto il peso di dover
uscire davanti al pubblico e di dover
fare dei discorsi seri ma ad un certo
punto mi sono dato un altro ruolo un
altro corpo e potevo fare quelle cose
che non si possono fare nella realtà
cioè arrivavo fuori dicevo tu come ti
chiami quello mi risponde da Paolo e con
questo che cosa vuoi dimostrare
diventando un altro le cose diventavano
più facili perché una volta trovato il
personaggio la strada è giusta la strada
diventa facile diventa leggera ogni cosa
che tocchi diventa diventa come dire
percepibile reale la strada della
leggerezza ci porta veramente in questa
direzione diventa tutto molto più facile
Purtroppo quando fai questa scelta
chiaramente non tutti la comprendono Nel
senso che l'antimagia spesso e
volentieri
sta in bilico Fra non tutti la
percepiscono categoria in una serata
usavo
delle battute che uso spesso e
volentieri che rivolgere per contattare
il tuo cervello c'è una fascia oraria o
c'è un numero verde
Hai mai provato a usare una pastiglia
per dormire un lassativo
contemporaneamente provaci
e giocavo Ste battute col direttore di
un'azienda cioè sono quelle cose che
negli anni 80
c'era questo tipo qua che mi ha
aspettato a fine dello spettacolo quando
ha fatto queste battute sapeva che lui
stava dicendo sì diceva il direttore che
è il mio amico è quello che mi ha
scritto
non si incapacità Guardate la favola mi
ha aspettato fino davanti all'ascensore
va avanti scusi volevo fare un'altra
domanda Che palle Guardate Ma questa
domanda lei sapeva che la persona che
gli ha fatto queste domande era il
direttore Appunto È lui che gli ho fatto
non percepiva questa lì a Domenica In
una puntata io venivo fuori vestito da
Silvano e uscivo fuori con tutti i
capelli qua andavo fra il pubblico e
pubblico però quel giorno mi ricordo ero
una camminata che veniva da Isernia non
so da qualche parte Arriviamo fra voi
dice bene Adesso signori sceglierò un
ignorante a caso
è chiaro non poteva percepire quel tipo
di rogna mi avvicino uno mi metto la
mano sulla testa e faccio sento vuoto
molto vuoto e dal fondo uno fa non si
dicono queste cose
È chiaro che questo tipo di ironia non
passa devi combattere hai scelto una
direzione Oggi è molto più facile perché
è stata sdoganata questa questa chiave
l'idea però è interessante è quella che
una volta scelto il mio personaggio una
volta scelto questo personaggio o gli
altri personaggi ho consegnato a loro
cose che prima non potevo fare perché ha
investito della mia personalità non
potevo esprimere e attraverso quella
leggerezza quella voglia di giocare
dentro questo dentro questo ruolo che
tutto diventa un po' più facile un
esempio lampante è questo questo è
veramente un grosso problema Io di
solito durante lo spettacolo prendo il
mazzo di carte faccio prima l'effetto e
poi scelgo una persona del pubblico
mette una carta in evidenza This is my
provision
Come ti chiami Scusa Paola
Sì Francesca
Valeria mentalista
pensa ad una carta quella che vuoi
perché l'hai pensata cambia la quella è
troppo facile
tesoro che faccio questo gioco ti metto
delle battute dentro tipo il mentalismo
e leggere nella mente delle persone che
è diverso che leggere nei buchi del
formaggio quello è elementalismo
se il pubblico applaudia queste battute
e la situazione
in realtà state notando che io sto
performando ma sto facendo diventare
qualcosa che niente perché non è ancora
iniziato io non ho fatto scenico nel
senso e questa è una strada facile
difficile facile perché non sto facendo
niente ma non sto facendo molto bene
nel senso che l'attenzione è la sto
gestendo ed è una linea è una strada una
strada facile mi con facile per me poi
se è facile per te devi trovarla facile
perché io posso giocare dentro questo
gioco senza fare nulla sto andando
avanti ed è una strada che non mi
comporta lo sforzo che molti fanno per
esempio fra mentalisti fra maghi che
devono ricordare devono fare un mio
amico che Memorizza 52 carte non è un
mal di testa solo pensare Io ancora hai
già saputo
hai pensato a quella carta vuoi dire
apertamente di fronte a tutti For the
First Time
Wet is your love
quale carta ad alta voce in modo tale
che tu ti possa servire quale carta è
mai pensato Esatto bene Grazie ciao
buona giornata
[Musica]
veniamo a noi
Io so che
l'82,3% del pubblico scegli la Regina di
cuori il 3 di Cuori o il 7 di cuori lo
so quando apro le carte Io metto in
evidenza il 3 di Cuori questo questa
carta la metto qua perché so che
[Musica]
all'82,3% la gente dice il 3 di cuore o
la donna di cuori e la fa è la prima
carta che ti viene in mente non deve
fare L'errore che faccio io di dire
cambia la quella è troppo facile perché
quella è una gag che io uso però quella
uccide il pensiero perché quando tu
dicevano pensano a carta subito quello
pensa a quel quelle tre carte non va
oltre Però cioè quel margine in cui
sceglie un'altra carta di solito quando
dice un'altra carta chiudo con questa
che Esatto quella che ho fatto prima
ma
tante volte la gente dice il 3 di Cuori
che carta hai pensato
E lui dice al 3 di Cuori e io faccio
così
a questo punto il pubblico fa
però pensando fra me e me mi dico è
meglio prendere la risata del esatto
o
è lì è un dubbio c'è un dubbio che tante
volte mi è capitato che quella avesse
detto il 3 di Cuori e io e ho fatto
esatto
ho buttato via il miracolo Ho buttato
via un miracolo ma L'ho scelta e non è
che l'ho fatto involontariamente proprio
ho scelto di dire Prendiamoci la risata
invece del Miracolo preferisco essere
più piacevole che essere diciamo super
uomo Anche se alla fine Fra le righe
insomma E quindi praticamente rimane
rimane questo dubbio e giro quella carta
e mostro il 3 di Cuori e mi prendo lo
stupore oppure prendo la gag faccio così
e dico Esatto Non lo so ti faccio una
domanda
cioè dove voi farete una domanda a me Al
mio tre mi chiedete Raul tu che cosa hai
scelto Ricominciamo quanto fino a tre
voi mi dite tutti insieme Raul Tu cosa
hai scelto uno due tre
[Applauso]
la leggerezza
[Musica]